hi and welcome to another episode of
charlie is so cool like today we're
going to be exploring the world of
terrible accents and beards drawn on
with pens so I have an account on
Twitter just like every other person on
the internet ever and a couple of days
ago I asked my followers on Twitter to
send me some questions and I said I
would answer them in a video so this is
that video and these are those questions
enjoy what is your favorite verb the
verb to cool like which is derived from
my name because I'm just that
egotistical means to fall in love with a
fridge so that guy he's cool liking do
you think you'd enjoy living in a smurf
community so does this mean I'd get to
be a smurf living in their community or
I'd be like this big giant guy who just
hangs around them all the time it's the
first one then I probably wouldn't enjoy
that because Smurfs are kind of weird
but if it's the second one then I
probably wouldn't enjoy that cuz Smurfs
are kind of weird do you ever get
stalked by people who say or you're the
guy off YouTube and if so how does it
make you feel the smiley face it's
happened quite a few times to me
actually and whatever it does happen
it's always pretty nice because whoever
I meet is always really friendly but
there was this one time that really
stands out to me when I was in Liverpool
Street Station and I was just kind of
standing looking blankly at nothing and
there was this guy walking past me who's
kind of staring at me and so I turned my
head and I looked at him and he went
like I'm not even over exaggerating
there's actually the noise he made if he
could be any superhero what would your
name be and what would be your
superpower
I would be melodica man and I would send
people to sleep with my soul tree sounds
of my melodica how long is your pinky
finger I've got a sparkly ruler please
don't judge me it's about two and a half
inches long great I don't what does that
mean nothing do you like pineapple on
pizzas I do very much enjoy pineapple on
pizzas but rowena can you please stop
asking questions what is that smell um I
think it's dinner cooking downstairs
boxers or briefs twinks or bears I'm
actually a big fan of the hybrid you
know the boxer briefs I don't know what
twinks are but I know bears are so bears
I hope that's the right answer
okay I wouldn't recommend googling
twinks and bears if you've got Google
safe search turned off what is your
favorite dinosaur generally I favor the
Tyrannosaurus Rex because of its little
arms but I'm also partial to a
triceratops doesn't really matter
because dinosaurs are all dead if you
had to choose between either having
Britney Spears Marilyn Monroe sexy feel
a live with you for a week who would you
choose my I mean I'm a guy right so
given this opportunity I would probably
go for the hottest person among these
candidates so defo sexy Phil I know
you've done a lot of TV appearances but
what woman is your favorite I did a
little interview for this program called
The Gadget Show on channel 5 and it was
just a short little thing about how I
got well known on the Internet and they
were having some internet competition I
don't know but after my segment had
finished it kind of went back into the
studio in this female host said that I
was really really attractive
that was my first TV experience do you
secretly wish that you were mrs. nerimon
Lowell
no and this isn't even funny right I am
NOT involved with marijuana in any way
other than him being my friend please
get off my back about this what song do
you secretly dance to when you're alone
[Music]
yeah I don't know the lyrics sorry I've
just been informed that my dinner is
ready so I'm gonna end the video here if
you want to follow me on Twitter then
you can go to twitter.com forward slash
cool like thank you for watching and
good bye